Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for tuning in.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
after a crazy four days,
March Madness is down
to the Sweet 16.
That's right.
We are down to 16 teams.
Three number-one seeds
and nine million commercials
for AT&T.
Yeah.
Of course, the Cinderella story
that everyone's talking about
is the 15th-seed
Saint Peter's Peacocks
who have made it
to the Sweet 16.
It's exciting for long-time fans
who have been following the team
since Thursday.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh...
Saint Peter's is the first team
from New Jersey
to make the Sweet 16
in over 20 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's right.
And if they go all the way,
they'll be the only team
to wear their championship rings
on their pinkies.
[ Laughter ]
N-C-A-Ohh!
Hey! Ohh! This guy!
[ Laughter ]
How can you not love their name?
They're the Peacocks.
This is the best thing
that happened to NBC
since the new "Law & Order."
[ Laughter ]
I love it.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today
confirmation hearings began
for Supreme Court nominee
Ketanji Brown Jackson.
The hearing process
will last four days.
It's basically C-SPAN's version
of Coachella.
[ Laughter ]
And I saw that the top
Republican leading the hearings,
Chuck Grassley, is 88 years old.
Wow.
When it was his turn to speak,
he was like,
"Tell us who you are
and then tell me who I am."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Jackson will face days
of tough questions.
Brett Kavanaugh was like...
[Slurring] "It'll be fine.
I did it for four days.
After the s-second day...
After the --
After the second day,
it's kind of a blur. It's fine.
It's like --
You're my best friend.
Hold my hair."
[ Imitates vomiting ]
But this is cool.
I saw that
Judge Jackson's parents
were at
the confirmation hearing.
Even crazier,
so were Chuck Grassley's.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?!
-Hey, you guys
remember last year
when that huge ship
blocked up the Suez Canal?
Well, the same company that owns
that ship is back in the news,
and it's for exactly
the reason that you think.
Listen to this.
-A massive cargo ship
is stuck in the mud
off the coast of Maryland.
The vessel,
called the "Ever Forward,"
grounded in the Chesapeake Bay.
-Yeah, the "Ever Forward"
got stuck.
[ Laughter ]
Which is why they're
renaming it the "Irony."
[ Laughter ]
Every few months, the owner gets
a call from the captain like,
"Okay. Don't be mad..."
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this.
I heard that Match just launched
a new dating app
for single parents called Stir.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Yep.
Their slogan is, "I'll join
your hell if you join mine."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And this is fun.
Today after a two-year hiatus,
Dairy Queen's
Free Cone Day returned!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And after
their two-year hiatus,
the McDonald's ice-cream machine
is still on hiatus.
I'm sorry.
Finally, guys, in Miami, a thief
broke into a sneaker store
and took 20 shoes.
But when he got out, he realized
he only stole the left sneakers.
[ Laughter ]
Officers were like --
[Imitates radio static]
"The suspect is 5'10",
200 pounds,
and running in circles."
No matter what happens,
I hope he realizes that 20 lefts
do not make a right.
We have a great show.
Give it up for the Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you.
-[ Rapping ]
♪ Drop top... ♪
♪ Attaboy...so savage ♪
♪ Making C's
seem so below average ♪
♪ Everyone in the cave... ♪
♪ Everybody know that...
like Bo Jackson ♪
♪♪
-Hey, everyone! It is Monday!
We're excited to be back.
We have a great week
of shows ahead.
Ethan Hawke will be here
this week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Desus and Mero
will be joining us!
And Joe Jonas
will be here this week.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then
we'll also be talking --
I want to -- I want to --
Yeah, I know.
I have a new book,
but we'll be talking about this.
-When?
-I don't want to do it now.
I don't know if I'm ready
to talk about it.
-When are you gonna be ready
to talk about it?
-I don't know if I'm
ready to talk about it now.
-Really? When you don't want
to talk about "Nana Now"?
-It's not "Nana Now."
-Oh, it's "Nah-nah," right?
-No, it's not "Nah-Nah."
-Nah, nah, nah, nah.
-No, no. It's "Nana."
-"Nana."
-It's not "Nah-Nah."
It's "Nana Loves You More."
-Oh, okay.
[ Audience awws ]
[ Laughter ]
-This one's a weeper.
-Really?
-Yeah.
I finally wrote a cry one.
-You wrote a crying one?
-You know,
the books that come out,
and they're nice,
you get them for the babies
and you get them
for the things --
And some are too sad.
-Yeah.
-There's one that --
You know what I'm talking about.
I'm not even gonna say the name.
-Oh, I know the one, I think.
-It is awful. It is so sad.
-Is it about carrying --
-Yeah, he's carrying his --
"I'll Love You Forever."
That one?
-Don't say it.
I asked you not to say the name.
It's too sad.
I had it removed from my house.
I said, "Appreciate the gift,
but please take it back."
-Yeah.
-Because it's too sad.
-She's carrying the baby,
then he carries the mom.
[ Audience awws ]
No, that's what I'm saying.
I can't do that.
-My kids
wouldn't do that for me.
-No, I can't do it --
This is cute cry.
-Oh, cute cry. Good, good.
-This is like -- Yeah.
Because who doesn't love
their grandma?
-Right.
-Their grammy.
Their gam-gam. Their gigi.
Their abuela. Their memaw.
What other names?
I got them all, right?
-You got them all.
-I got them all.
It's cute. It's a good one.
-But you don't want
to talk about it?
-No, I don't want
to talk about it.
I don't want to talk about it.
No, not tonight.
I'll talk about it
maybe tomorrow.
-Tomorrow?
-I want to have, like, a --
I'm thinking of having
a theme week.
But to do that, I --
It's a lot of scheduling.
-You have to work.
Too much work.
-Guys, but what a show
we have for you tonight.
She stars in the new movie
"The Bubble."
Leslie Mann is here!
-Oh, I love her!
-Leslie Mann!
-I love Leslie Mann!
-I love Leslie Mann. Ohh.
Speaking of love, you know him
from "Saturday Night Live."
Now he's the host
of the number-one show
on Netflix right now,
"Is It Cake?"
Mikey Day is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-"Is It Cake?"
-Literally the best.
It's just a simple --
just simple rules.
Is it or is it not cake?
It's a fun game. I love it.
And then we have --
Oh, my gosh. Fantastic music.
Kae Tempest is here.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kae Tempest is here!
Very exciting.
Oh, this is big, actually.
I saw that the daytime TV show
"Maury" is ending.
-Oh.
-Yeah. 31 years on the air
is quite a run.
-Oh, man. That's a shame.
"Maury" has been, like,
my favorite show.
-What?
That's not true.
"Maury" is not
your favorite show.
I bet you've never even seen
an episode, you liar.
-[ Scoffs ]
Don't you call me a liar!
You don't even know me!
You're the liar!
[ Audience oohs ]
-No, no, no, no, no. No.
You're the liar.
-Whoa!
-You are!
-Hey, hold on, guys, guys.
Calm down. Guys.
-Know what? I don't need this.
[Bleep] all y'all.
-Wait, wait, wait. What?!
-Oh, yeah! You heard me!
-Boo!
-Boo him!
-No, no, no, no, no, no! No!
I don't need any of you!
Aah! Blegh!
Forget it! [Fake sobbing]
-You better run! Man, that's
all you ever do, is run!
-Come on. Come on.
[ Audience jeering ]
-[ Fake sobbing ]
-Higgins.
You can't just storm out
every time you get upset.
-You're right.
-You know? You have to learn
to confront your problem.
You know that?
-Yeah. I know that.
-You ready to go back out there?
Let's do it.
Let's go back out there.
-Yeah.
-Mm-hmm.
Come on. Come on.
Let's go. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Fake sobbing ]
-That's alright.
[ Laughter ]
-[As Maury] Now we're gonna
get to the bottom of this.
Higgins actually took
a lie-detector test
before the show to prove
if he actually watches "Maury."
Alright.
And here are the results.
When asked, "Is 'Maury'
your favorite show?"
Higgins said yes.
-Yeah.
-The lie detector determined
that was...
a lie!
-Yeah!
-No! No!
-Yes! I told you!
-No!
-Whoo-hoo! Whoo-hoo-hoo!
-No! No! That's not --
Come on!
-Also, also,
our paternity test determined
you're the father
of 28 illegitimate children.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew that.
-Oh, okay.
Alright. Steve Higgins,
Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Stick around. We're playing
charades with Leslie Mann
and Mikey Day
when we come back, everybody.
♪♪